statistically speaking right if we
observed some sort of alien life it
would most likely be some sort of
virally
self-replicating vman like probe system
right and and it's
possible that there you know there are
such systems that I don't know what
they're doing at the bottom of the ocean
allegedly but maybe they're you know
collecting minerals uh from the bottom
of the ocean yeah um but that wouldn't
viate violate any of my prior but am I
certain that these systems are here and
it it'd be difficult for me to say so
right I only have secondhand information
about there being data about the bottom
of the ocean yeah but you know could it
be things like memes could it be
thoughts and
ideas could they be operating in that
Medium could aliens be the very thoughts
that come into my
head like what do you have you hm how do
you know that how do you know that the
what's the origin of ideas in your mind
when an idea comes to your head show me
where it originates I mean
frankly uh when I had the idea for the
type of computer I'm building now I
think it was eight years ago now it
really felt like it was being beamed
from
space It just I was in bed just shaking
just thinking it through and I don't
know uh but do I believe that
legitimately I don't think so I but you
know
I I think that um alien life could take
many forms and I think the notion of
intelligence and the notion of Life
needs to be expanded uh much more
broadly uh to be less
anthropocentric or
biocentric